じゃああの 色のルーパの分析の
まあ今日はできるだけ終わりますかどうか分かりませんだけど
今日はこのテキストに12と書いているところの
このヴィンヤッティルーパというところから始まります
180 あ それ終わったんですか？じゃあそれ終わります
13 の 変化色 ヴィカーラルーパ
で ヴィカーラルーパと
まあ一つと書いてるんですね
ルーパッサラフタムジュタカムアンニャッタタ
ヴィンニャッティドヤン
ヴィカーラルーパンナニ
そこら辺でまあきちんとした分析はちょっと狂ってしまっちゃうんです
ですから この まず変化色という言葉だけ覚えておけばいいんです
変化ですから 変化なんですね
結局ここで言ってるのは
この色自体が 物質自体が変化するということなんです
だから物質っていうのはもともと実体あるものではなく
ただのエネルギーの流れですから
どうせ流れなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから この基本的に物質というエネルギーは持っている特色は変化なんですね
変わるんですね 変わらなきゃ物質として存在はしないんです
で そこは普通の人間にはもう頭の中で誤解があるんですね
で どういう誤解かというと
我々にも世界の中で 我々にはこの変化がなければ生きていられないんです
で 変化がなければご飯も食べられないでしょうし
酸素を吸ったっても 酸素は体に入るわけじゃないし
体の中に変化が起ころなきゃ生きてるということはありえないし
で 電車に乗ってどこかも行けませんし
何もできなくなっちゃうんです
変化がなければ だからこの変化っていうのは常に基本的にあるもので
その変化自体が生命の場合は生きているというし
物質の場合はまあ物事は変わっていくんだと普通には言ってるんです
そういうふうな事実なんですけど
私たちはどうもこの変化は嫌なんですね
変化は嫌で もう何か永遠なものがないかとか
あるいはものは あの きちんと変化しないであってほしいという大変な努力をするんですね
その努力と生きるということはなかなか正反対である
例えばお金を 仕事をしてお金を儲けて
お金を何か貯めておこうと
あるいは まあ将来をきちんと確保しておき
確保しておきましょうとかね
そういうふうな考え方あるんですね
老後のためにとか で 収入なんかはきちんと固定して安定してした収入資源があればいいんじゃないかとか
で 就職する時でも きちんとした会社にも
もう潰れそうでもない
潰れそうもない会社に就職しなくちゃいけないとか思ったりするんです
で 我々の人生論っていうのは
そういう風に何か固定したもの
確固たるものを目指して努力する生き方であって
でも 生きるということは変化であって
全く相反するもので 矛盾なんですね
そんなことで もう真実の世界ではなくなっちゃうんですね
そこを理解しておいてくださいと
変化自体は認めなさいと
変化自体認めなきゃ もうもう決して真理を認めることにならないんですね
それで物質を見ても 心を見ても
ものすごく速さで 恐ろしい速さで変化していくんですね
どれぐらい速かというと
素粒子の速さですから
そんなに速さで我々は変化していく
地球も宇宙も全部変化していく
そこで何が捕まっておこうかということはあり得ないんですね
お金であろうか 名誉であろうか
健康であろうか 体力であろうか
何であろうか そんなものはもう変わるもんで
もう明日っていうものは
我々今からいくら希望したっても
明日っていうのももう変化してしまっちゃうんです
ですから 自分の希望通りに物事はいかないんだと思って悩んだりする
当たり前のことだ 希望通りにいかないんだから
すごいお金貯まっておく
老後は幸福に暮らそうではないかと
そこで老後になって突然病気などで倒れて
まあ脳卒中とか何とかなったところで
いくらお金があったって全然役に立てなくなっちゃうんです
そこですっごく精神的に悩んだりするんですね
自分の希望通りにいってないんだと
この世の中で神も仏もいないんだと
まあそれはいないんだけど
別に だから何ですかと聞きたいんだけど
ものすごい自然に逆らって
世の中は自分の希望通りにしてほしいと思う
その愚かさなんですね
ただ 自分の髪の毛を男性の場合は抜けたりするし
髪の毛が抜けない場合はもう白くなっちゃうんですね
どっちかもう 僕の場合はほとんど白くなっていくんです
あまり髪に落ちませんだけど
じゃあ白くなる 1本の髪でも
じゃあ黒くしておくことはできますかね
それぐらいのも我々にはできないんですね
自分の希望どおりにはいかないんです
全部変化している ですから
そこら辺は目に見えている事実で
毎日体験しているもので
生きているということは変化であって
たったお米を見て それを洗って水に入れて炊飯器に入れたら
たった 30 分で全く違うものに変化してしまうんだから
たまに 30 分もかからないんですね
大きな建物なんかも 最近大体火事の時期になってますからね
冬だから まあちょっと 15 分で
まあ 1年  2年頑張って
あるいは一生頑張ったところ
建物なんか全部灰になってしまっちゃいますから
変化っていうのはいつでも自分の目の前にいつでもあるもので
それでそれでも変化は嫌だ
嫌だと思うのはなぜですかと
それを我々に聞かなくちゃいけないんです
なんで自分がこんなに変化嫌ですかと
それすごい人間の生命の愚かさなんですね
変化が嫌というならば
もう自分には何もなくなくなっちゃうんですね
例えば我々は努力すれば幸福になりますよと
それも変化ですから 変化嫌という人は
いくら仕事をしたってもお金は儲かりませんし
ご飯食べても全然そのまんまお腹に入ったまんまで
そのまま動かない そうするともう死んでしまっちゃいますから
ですから この変化は嫌というところじゃないんです
そう嫌と思う心さえ変化するんだ
ですから 仏教でとことんこういう分析学を分析をして教えたかったというのは
全ては変化すること自体が普遍的な真理であって
色いくつあるかということはそんなに大事じゃないんです
物質は何種類あるんですか？何種類あったってもう関係構いません
どうせ変化するものだから
ですから もうきめ細かく分析するんだけど
この分析自体もいろいろややこしいこと
いい加減なものもあったり
例えばキッチンとした地水火風なんかあって
それからこのあかさですか
空間も入ってて 空間なんて別に空間はないんだよ
ただ他の色のがの間が空間で
それも色ですよと なんか全然
分断して別になんかいい加減ではないかと
ですから別に色は 28あるか 20ですか
4ですか  8ですかということよりは
すべてのものは変化していくんだ
例えば空間にしたっても変化するんだから
ある物質があるんだから空間が生まれてくるんですね
その物質の移動によってその空間が変化するんだから
ですから そこにさえその変化というものはあるんですね
そこで物質論を下げているところで
アビダルマでは じゃあこの変化もやっぱりとことん強調しておかなきゃいけないんです
そういうことで この変化自体が強調しようと思って
変化色が 5つあるんだと言ってるんです
でも変化色 5つあって
他の色は変化しないんですかというと問題でしょ
本当のところは変化色っていうのは 5つないんです
すべてのものは変化するんです
ですから すべての物質的なエネルギーに対するある特色を
ある物質の根性 物質の本当の性質を変化色で言ってるんですから
論理的に言えば別に独立した色ではないんです
だからそこら辺まだまだもうしっかりとアビダルマももうちょっと発展した方がいいなというところかもしれません
例えば 物質は区別して分別して説明したならば
これぐらいの物質は推測できますよと
それから その物質の特色という項目を作って
その物質のこういうこういう特色がありますよというふうに言った方がもっと整理しますが
まあその前にアビダルマは一応止まってしまったかもしれませんし
そこまで発展していないんですね
ですから一緒になっているんです
ごちゃ混ぜに ですから
今日説明するこの変化色っていうのは
決して色ではないんです
別に別なものではないんです
でも 5つありますよと言ってるんです
どういうことかというと
色 軽快性 軽快性 柔軟性
適応性という 3つまず出てくるんですね
そこでも説明してないし
注釈書にもないと思いますけど
こちらで言ってるのはとにかく古い経典とかいろんなところにあるんだから
こういう言葉を使ってあって
まず色の軽快性 ルーパッサラフタって何ですか？と
パーリ語でラフタと言うんですね
ラフタというのこの言葉の通りにも軽快
軽いという意味なんです
色は色にはこの軽さという性質があるんだという意味なんですね
軽い そう言ったっても
どんな意味ですかと で
色と大体の言うのは地水火風なんですね
ですから そのその地水火風にはその地の元素
それは私の解釈で注釈で
伝統的な注釈にはそういうふうにないんです
ですから そこら辺分別して考えてください
このテキストではそこはあるかどうか分かりません
で そのその現象に地水火風で出来上がってるんだから
地は地っていうのは硬さですね
ですから重さですね ですから
我々知っているものには決まってる重さがあります
英語で言うとデンシティといってというんですね
例えば水は 1で 1に比べていろんなものに数字が入れてるんですね
で いわゆる 1 1 立方センチメートルですか
1グラムだと思えば どれぐらい？どれそこで重さが
重さですね 質量ですね
そこで計算するのは で
軽快じゃなくて そういうふうに物に大体我々知ってるものには決まってる硬さ
仏教では硬さ 質量というものあるんです
そこでいくらが決まってるようなんですけど
その同じものもその硬さが変わる
変わる可能性あるんです
その物として別に変わったわけじゃないんだけど
重さが変わる可能性あるんです
より軽くなる可能性あるんです
いわゆるあの 1 立方センチというんですか
そのセンチの水が 1G 1G ではなくて
もしかすると 0.9G から 0.8 とかね
グラムにもなる可能性あるんです
いわゆる質量の働きが変わるということなんですね
地位の働き でも物質として現象としてはそんなに変わったわけじゃない
鉄とスチールと見れば
鉄の方が軽くてスチールの方が硬い
というものもあるし 同じものでもそういう硬さ
軽さっていうのはありまして
この そこはまあ化学の世界でじゃなくて
物理学の世界ではね やっぱりあのグレードですか
作ってるんですね カーボンと言ったっても
全ては炭素ということではなくて
炭素の何番かと その番号によってどんな位置にいるかということは
炭素には変わりはありませんだけど
その数字が変わっちゃうんですね
付け加えているその数字っていうのは
その原子の重さで で だから原子の重さが重いほどものは重いし硬いし
軽くなるとそれなりに軽い軽いし
で そういうふうなことがあって
そういうふうな変化は本当の変化につながっちゃうんです
例えば鉄を硬くしようと思っていろいろ変化させちゃうと
どんどん鉄は鉄でなくなってしまっちゃうんですね
鉄を軽くしてみようと思っていろいろやってみると
どんどん鉄は鉄の性質を失って違うものになってしまっちゃうんですね
それ今説明したのは 我々知ってる物理的な世界の話で
仏教では小さい化合の話で言ってますから
ものの地の割り当てがバッテリーの割り当てが少なくなる可能性あるんです
どうせそんなもの逃げていっちゃいますから
少なくなるとそのものは
軽さ持っちゃうんですね
で そういうことで あまりこの我々の体験ではなかなか分からないものかもしれません
でも少々科学的なものを考えると
やっぱり元素には決まってる重さがないということはお分かりになると思いますけどね
決まってる重さがない
ある幅があって ここからここまでの重さはなんとかなんとか元素だと
もっと重くなっちゃったら違う元素だよと
ふうになっちゃうんですね
ですから 炭素は僕は別に調べていないんだけど
わかりませんだけど この重さからこの重さまで炭素でって決まってるんですね
そこからもっと上になったら違う元素になってしまっちゃうと
いわゆるアトミックウエイトと言いますけどね
この そういう元素の重さ
そういうものは一応我々頭の中では分かっているもので
それは科学者がそう言うんだけど
我々それでも実感できないものなんですけど
とにかく物質にはそういう性質があるんです
変化によって それ簡単にできますね
例えば水を 度 四度ぐらいの水の水を測って
ちゃんと 一五センチメートルぐらい持ってきて
それはまあ度にするとして見れば軽いんですね
一立方センチメートルの水っていうのは
ですから どうやって軽くなってるんですかというと
やっぱり質量が大きさはないですけど
やっぱり質量がないんですね
値を作る元素が外へ出て行ってるんです
この極普通にこの物質の伸び縮みとして喋っているのは
大体そういう似ているものなんです
いわゆるこのエネルギーの変化なんですね
組み合わせの変化 その変化はなんでここで軽さと言いますかというと
やっぱり質量を通して軽くなるということ
いわゆるこのある物体が物体の質量値の元素がパターンの元素がちょっと変化しましたと
そうするとその現象が軽くなるという変化は起こしてしまっちゃう
そういうことで 式の軽快性と言うんです
あの心を清らかにすると
これは瞑想のためにあるものだから
心をどんどん清らかにすると
それから集中すると 心っていうのはかなり元気になるんですね
すごく我々は心をいじめているんだから
で 心が元気になってくると
心がかなりの物質作ってるんです
体中 この食べ物はそんなに物質作ってるわけじゃないんで
食べ物よりたくさん物質が心で作ってるんです
で そこで心が清らかで
それなおかつ集中力があってという状態続くと
あまり長く続く必要ないんです
たった一日 二日 三日続けてしまえば
自分の体がすっごく軽く感じるんです
タンポポのように 綿のように
体重はそんなに気にならなくなっちゃうんです
普通の人にとっては 欲があったり
怠けがあったりすると
体を運ぶのは大変なんです
怒りがあったりとかね
いつでもそんなことだから
困ったりしていると 悩んだりしていると
体っていうのは重くて重くて
で 心が明るくなってきて
集中力が出てくると 体っていうのは自分実感としてすごく軽いんだと
ものすごく軽いと感じるんです
それは妄想 概念でもなんでもないんです
自分の心がそう認識しているんだから
それは実体なんです 実体ではなくて
それは事実なんです その場合は
その人を計りに入れて測ってみた方がいいかもしれません
なかなかそういう実験はできないんです
本当にそうやってみた方が確かに本当に軽くなったか
あるいは軽くなったという実感だけですかとか
それまあどうでしょうかとちょっと考えたことがあるんだけど
まあなかなかそれはまあ
瞑想するところとそういう実験するところっていうのは環境は違うんだから
実験するところに行ったら
決して瞑想はまだ書いてできないし
だから実験室にいて ずっと瞑想して
自分で心は体が軽く感じたところで
もう体重を測ってみようと思ったっても
そういう環境ではなかなか落ち着かないんですね
で まあそれはともかく
そういう事実はあるんです
瞑想の世界では で どんな重い体の人であろうか
体が重くて座るのも大変で
歩くのも大変でとかね
そういうふうにあっても
どんどんどんどん心が集中していく
それで心の汚れが消えて
悩みが消えていって 明るくなってくると
自分の体っていうのはものすごい自由自在に動けるような
すっごく軽いもので感じる
その現象を見ているんですね
アビダンマでは この実際の体という物体があるのに
その物体に軽さというものが現れるんだと
そこまですごい気持ちいいんですから
軽快式になっているんです
パーリ語ではラフタという言葉で
軽さというぐらいの意味なんですね
で アビダンマは一つ論理的に説明するならば
軽さはなぜ生まれるかというと
この地の働き パタウィの働きが
パタウィのエネルギーの波動が控えていっちゃうということなんです
そのエネルギーは機能しなくなっちゃう
例えばこの磁石の力 何て言いますか
磁力ですか 磁力っていうものはどんなものにもあるんですね
別に あるんだけど 働かないんですね
機能はしない で 鉄にしたっても
例えばこの地球は別に鉄の塊ではないんだけど
ちゃんと磁場があります
たりして で 鉄にしたっても
その組み合わせによって磁力
磁力が働くかないかということなんですね
という現象はあるんです
鉄なんですけど なかなか磁石にはならないんだと
分子が磁石になるように並べないんだということはあるんです
でももともとあることはあるんです
分子一個一個にありますから
そういうふうに この同じ体という物体にはパタウィはあるんだけど
パタウィだけすっごく並んで頑張っちゃうと
体が硬くて重くてという状態が出てくる
それは人間の感情から見れば
硬くて重くて面白いということはないんですね
自分の体がすっごい 硬くて重くて気持ちいいという人はいませんね
大体軽くて気持ちいいという方は気持ちいいんですね
そこで瞑想していっちゃうと
その軽い方にいってしまっちゃうんです
そういうこと 次にあまり説明するともう時間なくなります
次の式はムドゥータというんですね
ムドゥータ ムドゥータというのはこっちも書いてるようなこの柔軟性なんですね
ソフトネス すごくこの
柔軟 ぐにゃぐにゃみたいな状態っていうことなんですね
それもよく考えると この地水火風の組み合わせはちょっと変化する
鉄はすごく硬いんだけど
もうかなり温めておけば
なんかドロドロみたいな状態になってしまっちゃうんですね
まあ赤くなっただけでも鉄は柔軟性持ちますからね
どんな方向にも軽く曲がってしまっちゃうんですね
鉄を曲がる場合は やっぱり温めたので赤くなったところで
もう何のことなく曲がってしまっちゃう
冷たくなったらそんな簡単には曲がりません
それもっともっと白い状態に持ってきて
もっと赤かっつったら
なんかドロドロみたいな状態にもなるんですね
でも鉄ではなくなっちゃいます
というと そうじゃない
鉄は鉄です 鉄は鉄でもあるのに
地水火風の組み合わせが変わるんです
変わるんだから そういう柔軟性を持つようになっちゃいますね
そこでどうやって柔軟性になりますかというと
このそれはまあ 水の働きなんですね
で ドロドロ状態になりますから
やっぱり地水火風の水の働きが機能して
その柔軟性が生まれてしまうんです
表に出るようになるんですね
現れるようになってしまうと
で それは瞑想している人々は
まあまあ どう感じる 感じるかないか分かりませんだけど
感じる場合はその自分の体の柔軟性として感じちゃうんです
軽さというよりは 例えば足は組むことが全くできなかった人が
どんどん瞑想していって
瞑想うまくいっていると集中力が出てくると
なんのことなく足組めるようになっちゃうんです
今まで膝が曲がらなかったという人は
もう硬くて何のことなく膝が曲がってしまっちゃうんです
大体骨折とか硬くなるでしょう
年取ってくると あれ 何て言いますか
この何とか病気ですね
何と言いますか  え？ ええ
この アーサイトイったかなんかがありますね
そういう軟骨はね 硬くなったりして
もう曲がったりは曲がること
よく出てくるのは膝なんですね
え？で それからすごく痛いんですね
それからは で そういう風になってきたら
人々というのは足すのは嫌で
座るのは嫌で 階段はもう上がれませんし
すっごくもう強烈に痛い
それ我々の常識の世界なんですね
でも もし瞑想してみたら
こんなわがまま言わないで
その人に限ってすっごいわがまま言うんですね
私はもう長い間座っていられませんと
だから私たちに何言うんですか？と聞きたいんだけど
こちらの方こそ私たちのせいみたいな感じで
だから瞑想できねえから勝手にしなさいと
別に怒ったことないんだけど
難しい長い人のせい 勝手だから
だから親切には指導したくなくなっちゃうし
指導もできないんですね
指導してそういう風に不必要なこと言っちゃったら
どうもそのエネルギーは繋がりません
とにかく まあそんなことをなく
やっぱり頑張ってみようと思って
そんな体はどうでもいいやと思って
心さえ綺麗になればいいんじゃないかという風に覚悟を決めてやっちゃうと
この集中力と心の清らかさですね
その両方必要なんです
生まれてくると 今まで硬い硬い痛い痛いと言ったところは何のことなく曲がっちゃうんです
で 物質は変わるんです
柔軟性になってしまっちゃうんです
それはそれで永久的に病気が治ったかというと
そうじゃなくて 心は綺麗でいる限り
心はまた高慢に戻ってわがままに戻ったら
またご褒美として 痛みやら硬さやら苦しみは戻ってくるんです
そういうことは事実としてあります
ですから この軽くなるか
柔らかくなるかという
次に適合性ですね この適合性もこの軽くなるということって似ていて
やっぱり軽いんだったら柔軟性あったら当たり前で適合性が出てくるんです
でも この修行によってよくやるでしょ
この空手やらこういうやってる人々がいろいろ心を訓練して
体も訓練して 手で瓦を破ったりとか
大変役に立つことをやってくれるでしょ
瓦 二 三枚ぐらいも何のことなくパッてやっても割ったりするんですね
で 私達やっちゃったら病院行きですけど
私がやっちゃったら病院なんですけど
その人々は別になんのことなく
手で瓦二 三枚ぐらい ペンが一枚
二枚ぐらいはまあ割ってしまう
それで人々は大変役に立っていると
お金も儲かってますからね
で その場合ももうやっぱりこのただ手で訓練しただけでは割れませんね
やっぱり心も必要なんですね
その場合でも ですから心を集中して
それでそれによって体も適合性が生まれてくるんです
その場合の適合性っていうのは硬さなんですね
手にすごい硬さが生まれてくる
そういうのを喜んでいる人々もいるんです
ですから 適合性っていうのは必ずしも柔らかさということでもないんです
逆立ちできない人がいてとかね
どうせ逆立ちしたいと
その場合は両手にすごくバランスをとって
重さを持てるような硬さが必要なんです
これぐにゃぐにゃ状態に手が手がそうなったら
もう逆立ちはどうしてもできなくなっちゃうし
で このインドのこのヨガの世界でいろんなことをやってるでしょ
もうヨガとしていろんなもう自問自答になってるんですね
例えば足をちゃんと組んで
足の中に手を入れて手で立っているとか
片手で足を組んで片手で立っているとか
あるいは逆立ちで頭で立って
足を上でちゃんと組むとか
で そういうこともやっぱりいくらかこの心と体が集中できたところで
いとも簡単にできるもんなんですね
それをやりたくてみんなヨガなさってますけどね
それできる人にはね それから何ができるかと聞きたいんだけど
ただそれだけなんですけど
まあ僕にはできないんだけど
例えばまあまあやってみればできると思いますけど
恥ずかしいのでやりませんけど
例えばこの逆で頭で逆立ちをする
それからきちんと足を綺麗に組む
普通我々は まあ私でも足を組む場合は
手で足を引っ張って組んであげなきゃ
もう勝手に組めないぐらい硬いんですね
でもその人は何のことなくきちんと足を組める
頭にも体にもそれ必要な硬さが生まれてきて
柔らかさも生まれてきてる
そういうふうなことは適合性と言ってる物質の変化なんです
またありますね ヨーガの
なんていいますか このこうやってなんか後ろを見て
なんかすごい変なことするんですね
足なんか足を上げて首にかけて
背中を後ろを曲がってみたりとかね
いわゆる普段普通の人には全部できないものなんです
このヨーガのアサナっていうのは
シャバーサナ以外は普通の人にはなかなかできないんですね
シャバーサナっていうのは
死体の形といって ただ上に寝るだけのことで
それは誰にでもできますけど
他のアーサナはなかなかできないもんなんです
ですから そこはやっぱりやってみると
どんどん集中力も生まれてきて
できるようになってきますね
だから その物質のその性質
ここで 3つに分けて説明してるんです
ラウタムドゥタカンマンニョタ
ラウタっていうのは軽快性
柔軟性 それから適合性
それにそのミスでいいのに
この前説明したこの標識も入れてるんです
この前の勉強会で最初に説明した標識 2つあったんですね
カーリニョとワチーリニョっていう
それもまたここに入ってるんです
ダブってるんですね ここにとっても
もう 2つ もう簡単に抜けちゃうんです
28 式じゃなくて もうここで 26 になっちゃうんですね
そこで 26 といったっても
ラウタムドゥタカンマンニョタ別な式ではないんだから 23 になっちゃうんですね
そこでこの前言っちゃったこの分断式っていうのは分断式は存在しないんだから
21 に 22 になっちゃうんですね
もっと少なくなるんです
計算してみると  私の説明よりはこちらの説明はすごくわかりやすいみたいですね
季節が良い時などにおける色欲の軽い状態をいいと
大体そんなもんなんですね
軽い時点 例えば我々でも
やっぱり春になってくるとなんとなく体が元気でしょ
ああいうことだと でもやっぱり説明じゃない
なんで軽くなってくると体が元気ですかというと
やっぱり心が明るいんですね
そろそろ花が咲くでしょうと
そろそろ暖かくなってくるでしょうと
日が長くなってくるでしょう
すごくこの明るい方向へ考えちゃうんです
その時になってくると
梅の花が咲いたんだと
まあそろそろ暖かくなるよとか
そういう風に明るい方向へ考えちゃう
だからみんな元気なんです
ですから この心明るくて余計な悩み苦しみがなく
集中力が生まれてくると
本当にそういう物質の変化が起こるんです
食欲が盛んな盛んと読むんですか？そこは
食欲は盛んなという体が軽いんですかね
それ僕はちょっとわかりませんけど
まあ楽しい時は軽く感じますけど
まあとにかくこの変化式といったっても
まだまだ変化は説明足りませんね
この 5つでは それで私も分かりません
このカエリンヤティ ワチリンヤティ
なんで変化色というんですかと
新標色ですか？新標色
護法標色っていうのは
なんで変化色に入るかっていうと
ちょっとわからない まあ何か考えたでしょうね
わかりませんだけど 正直は
次のところに行きましょう
14番目にラッカナルーパ
相色 そこでまた無常のことを説明するんです
ラッカナルーパ  4つあります
このラッカナという名前っていうのは
このだいたいこのこっちは相と書いてますけど
このこれ仏教用語では大変大事な言葉なんですね
現象であろうが色であろうが
心であろうか この特色
その自分には自分たる何か訳があるんですね
その場合 使っている言葉なんですね
例えばプリサッサ プリサラッカナン
イッピッサ イッピラッカナンとかパーリ語で言っちゃえば
プリサッっていうのは男
男の男としての相と言えば
なぜ男か男かというかと
その特色いろいろあるんですね
男としてあるものを区別するためにどうしてもなくてはならないもの
そういう場合はラッカナですね
女の人といったら 女の人としていうためにはどうしてもなくてはならない特色はラッカナというんですね
ですから テーラワーダ仏教でも
初期仏教でも だいたい部派仏教でも
現象にはそういう自分の特色があるんだと言ってるんですね
大乗仏教はそんなものは全くないんだと一生懸命批判しているんです
特色はないんだと どっちが正しいかっていうのはまた別の話です
それは仏教の差なんですけど
このこのテーラワーダ仏教と
また大乗仏教が現れる前あったいろんなインドの仏教の中でも
一部 特に一切有部 設設一切有部と鏡量部という
で また何でしたっけ いくつかの部派仏教なんですけど
やっぱり物事には特色はあるんだと
現象には というふうなことを言っているんです
初期仏教でも別にこんなくだらない哲学はないんだから
ごく普通にこの人女の人だ
この人男の人だ まあそうですよって言うんです
これ大乗仏教 そんなことはありっこはない
男も女もない みんな仏やと言うのはもう大乗仏教のことで
まああなたは男で あなたは女ですよと
お釈迦様だったらそう言うんですね
で 別にとったことないんだから
犬も猫も女も男もみんな仏やって
で 何がありがたいか 何が偉い点か分かりませんだけど
そこで偉い哲学だから一生懸命弟子入りして勉強するといういいところがあるんですね
ですから もう立派になりたければ
もう訳も分からないことを言えばいいんです
そんなに難しくないんです
もし皆様方好き勝手に訳も分からない
どうでもいいくだらない言葉作っても僕に来てください
僕は哲学作ってみせます
何でもいいんです それぐらいこの頭の回転というのは
それぐらいではまだやってみせてないんだからね
頭の回転というのはもういくらでも回転するんですよ
回転するようにできているものだから
いつでも回転する ですから
もう世の中で もう男も女も全然その区別はありませんよって言っちゃったら
もう別にもうどんな立場からでも区別はないと言えるし
だからなんです だから何にもならないならないだけなんです
じゃあ人間も動物も他の生命も全く違いはないんですよと
も言えるし ちょっと立場変えるだけのことだから
じゃあ植物も生命も全部同じだと
それでも言えるし 別にちょっと立場変わるだけだから
物質の世界 地球も生命も全くみんな同じだと
区別は全くないと言えるでしょうね
ちょっと立場変えればそういうふうに言えるし
それだけ立場だけ変えればいいんです
例えばこの地球でいろいろ変化が起こって
化学的な物質からどんどんアミノ酸が出てきて
この生命の初めの DNA の構造ができたと
ですから もう単なるアミノ酸であって何もないんだと
言えばそれはそうでしょうし
ですから そこで男も女もではなくて
植物もなくなっちゃうんですね
ただの地球の化学的な物質だけですと
構造違い いろいろ構造ができただけのことではないかと
そんなふうに立場変えればまあ変わるんですね
あるいは人間の脳細胞の働きを考えて
いろんな思考をしたり
文化を作ったりするでしょ
それでやっぱり人間こそがこの地球上の唯一の生命体だよとも言えますよ
なぜならば犬猫は文化を作ってないんだから
脳細胞があるのに 猿も自分の猿文化っていうものを作ってないんだから
人間がいろんな文化作るは考えるは喋るは
ですから それは人間だけやってない
ですから 人間はこの地球上に現れた一番優れている特別な生命体ですよとも言えるし
あるいは生命で何のこともない
ただの地球同じものだとも言えるし
ただ立場変えて何か探ってるだけ
何の意味もないんです
そんなものに人間が執着して
えらく争論したり 喧嘩したり
枝分かれしたりしながらやってるんです
今日同じことが仏教の世界でも出てきて
この現象の中でこの実体はない状態
実体ない変化するんだから
これというものは掴まれません
それに初期仏教では空と言うんですね
シューニャータと言うんですね
ただそれだけとって 全ては空であると一生懸命宗教システムを作った
作ってしまいちゃう ただそれだけ
じゃあ頑張ってくださいと
別に全ては空ですよ シューニャですよと言ったっても
寒い時は私は寒いんだから
風邪を引いたら体調がものすごく悪くなってこすれちゃいますから
それには変わりはありませんし
私に悪口言ったら腹が立つし
悪口言われたら一切開口
一切開口と言ったってもね
別に何の意味もないんです
ただの頭の遊びなんですね
ですからこの哲学っていうのはそんなもので
もう何でも言えるんです
そこで仏教で言っているのは
こういう哲学に対するこの悟りっていうのは
一番段階の悟りっていうのは
こういう このありとあらゆる概念に対するこの未練は消えちゃう
よくわかって ああそうかそうか
頑張ってくださいと ぐらいで自分がそこに入り込まない
何の意味もないんだ だからはっきり言えば
全ての物事はシューニャであって空であるという大乗仏教の教えは
それはそれで正しいんです
その立場から見ると じゃあ
初期仏教はテーラワーダ仏教で言っているこういう色はこれこれやっていろいろ特色がありますよと
いわゆるそういう分別論ですね
分別論 分別論間違ってる
間違ってるよというのは大乗仏教だけなんです
なぜならば 大乗仏教はある立場でも
その立場で見れば間違ってるんです
でも 私たちの立場で見れば
それは別に間違っているわけじゃないんです
それだけのこと 一応そこでこの色はこれといっぱいありますよ
説明して 次にラックナという特色の世界を説明するんですね
特色というか この相というか
この言葉自体は仏教用語ではちょっと気になる言葉なんですね
テーラワーダ仏教でも他の部派仏教でも
現象が自分 あるものを通して持っている性質を表す場合は
この言葉を使っているんです
いわゆるパテリー 地は地たるもの
水 あーぽーはなぜあーぽーになりますかと
なんであーぽーとパテリーがごちゃ混ぜにならないかというと
あーぽーにはあーぽーの特色があって
パテリーにはパテリーの特色があります
その分別する 分別可能になる相
ラックナというんです
それはちょっとした後の時代の解釈でしたけど
そんなもんなんです そこでラックナは四つあります
ここでいうラックナはまた違います
ルーパッサウパチャヨサンティティジャラタアニッチャタ
ここで説明しているこのラックナは四つがありますけど
本当はたった一つでも構いません
それは仏教で言っている無常なんですね
で この前の説明でなかなか無常まで行かなかったんですね
軽快性 柔軟性 なんとか性でしたから
適合性 なんか説明足りなくなっちゃったんですね
それでまた項目一つ作って
相を作ると そこで無常を説明していて
しようとしているんです
そこでどういう風に物質の無常
これ心の無常じゃないんです
覚えといてください これは物質の無常
心の無常はちょっと違うんです
ルーパッサウパチャ 一番目はルーパッサウパチャヨ
[紙をめくる音]これはどういうふうに読みますか？セキ？セキ・セキシュウ
積集と書く積っていうのは
この積み重ねる集まるっていう感じで
テキストにありますから
積集 どういう意味ですかね
積集っていうのは ルーパっていうのはエネルギーでしょ
エネルギーっていうのはどんな
どういうことですかね
いつでも集まっちゃうんですね
あるところに流れて集まっちゃうんですね
だって  今皆様いろいろテープレコーダー回してますけど
この電池の中にはどうせエネルギーはあると思ったら
この電池のエネルギーは消えてるんではないかと
じゃないんです で このテープレコーダーの中にあるいろんな電気的原子的な部品がありますね
その部品もエネルギーを持ってるんです
その部品に電池のエネルギーが集まっちゃうんです
集まって最終的にはこのレコーディングヘッドですか
このちょっとした鉄のほんの小さなところがありまして
そこまでエネルギーは集まる
集まって磁場が作っちゃう
それに触れてる このビニール製のテープの中にある
この磁場ができるような
なんかものを塗ってますから
そこはまた変化してしまっちゃう
それは我々は録音だと言ってるんだけど
そこで そういう物質が他のところのエネルギーは自分で集まってもらうという働きであります
それは一つ それは大事なんです
エネルギーはある エネルギーは他のエネルギーを集まらなきゃテープレコーダーは存在しないんだから
私たちの体も存在しないんだから
外のエネルギーを集まってもらっちゃう
裸足で歩いたら今は寒くて
足がもう大変きつい状態になりますから
あるいは夏でも裸足歩いたら足が怪我するんだから
草履やら靴やら履くでしょう
すぐに草履やら靴やら
そのもののエネルギーで我々はもうちゃんと立って歩いたりはするし
他のエネルギーはどうしても使ってるんですね
他のエネルギーは体で吸収する
で 早く歩きたいんだと
でも自分の足の動きでは早く歩けないんだから
自転車に乗って自転車をこぐと
そうすると早く行ってしまっちゃう
自分の体のエネルギーと自転車のエネルギーは一緒になって早く動くっていうこと出てきて
まあ別に説明しなくなっても分かりやすいことで
たとえ今我々使っているテープレコーダーでも
テープレコーダーの各部品が電池に入っているエネルギーを集まるっていうことで
テープレコーダーっていうことを存在させちゃうんです
そうでないとテープレコーダーではない
ただの物体になってしまっちゃう
それ一番目 ウッペッチェー
どんなエネルギーにもその働きがあります
そこでウッペッチェーだけだったら面白いもんですね
全部増えますから それだけでもないんですね
たまに増えるものありますね
ゴミとかね どんどん増えると
減ることはないという
まあ本当は自然に増えるものっていうのは困るもんなんですね
自然に減るものは本当は減ってほしくないんですね 2
番目はサンテキ そちらの2番
サンテキっていうのは地足かな
そうそく そうそくという言葉です
このサンテキっていうのはやっぱり流れなんですね
流れているんだと 流れる場合は大体同じ速度で流れるんです
この言葉も仏教では大変大事にする一つの考え方なんです
物事はサンテキであるんだと
心も一つのサンテキですと
すべてのものはサンテキですという言葉をよく使うんです
それはこの魂ですということのために反対に言っている言葉なんです
あるいは何か変化しないものがずっとあるんだと言ったら
あまりにもバカバカらしいことで
仏教で認めないんです
あるのは流れですと 波ですと
湖の向こう側 こっち側
私がいて 指で水をいじっちゃうと波が立つ
その波が湖の向こう側まで行くんですね
波として行くんだけど
こちらの水はそのままなんです
こちら側 石を一つ落としちゃったら
そこで波一つ立つ そちらの水はそのまま
なのに波だけ向こう側に行ってしまう
じゃあこちらから何か向こう側まで行ったんですか？と
全然何も言ってないんです
こちらの水はそのまんまだから
そこは目に見えるサンタティなんです
流れなんです こちらから何もずっと糸みたいなもの流れたわけじゃないんです
エネルギーといったって物質なければエネルギーの表現力がないんだから
ですから 私は石を落とすというエネルギーを
水の分子に分子という物質の媒介して表現するんです
そこでその表現終わっちゃうんです
でもそれからもそのエネルギーというのは波として
次の次の水の分子に伝わってあげる
伝えてあげる それが波というものが成り立つ
だからこの物理学で言ってる波ですから
この波動ということは大変大事なことで
仏教ではそれをサンタティという言葉でよく使っているんです
そこでサンタティの特色はこういうことなんですね
同じものなんですね すすくのは
受け入れの場合は変わるかもしれませんね
例えば電池のエネルギーを集めてスピーカーから出ると音なんですね
全然電池の中にあったエネルギーじゃないんです
ものすごい違うものになっちゃうんですね
でもサンタティの場合はそうじゃないんです
例えばこの今我々が見ている蛍光灯の光はサンタティなんですね
流れなんです ですから
スイッチ入れた時からもずっと光が流れていくんですけど
似ているんですね 前の光と今の光
その特色にサンタティというんです
みんな誤解するのはそこら辺わかってないんだからなんです
魂があるんだとか みんな思っているのは霊魂があるんだと
このサンタティの働きはわかってない
誤解している よくよく理解すると
これは波 波ということは
こちらから何か向こうまで行くんじゃないんです
同じパターンの連続という意味
そうそう でも全く新しいものなんです
パターンは同じですけど
で 細胞の分裂はいくらか算的なんですね
一つの細胞は分裂する
二つになる その二つの細胞も前の細胞にほぼ似ている
ほとんど似ている だから私たちは同じものだと誤解する
ですから 生まれた赤ちゃんはもう今すでにないでしょうに
でも我々は同じものだと
お母さんたちが産むのはものすごい小さい
軽い 柔らかい ほんのちょっとの細胞の塊である
もう柔らかい生き物なんですね
それをもう人ぐらい経つと
それ私の子どもでよというのを
それ全く嘘なんですけど
私が産んだ子どもですよ
冗談じゃないんですよ
二十ぐらい 産めるわけないんだから
母よりもまあ一・五倍ほどでかいからな
あれは算的の誤解 似てるんです
お腹の中に一個の細胞
それは二つに四つに十六にとくなっていったりして
それで でも完全に同じだったら問題ないんで
完全に同じじゃないんです
似てるだけ 完全に同じだったら大変ありがたいんだけど
そうはないんです ただ
水の中で私はここらで波を作っても
その波は向こう側から行くんだけど
完全に同じものでないんですね
向こうに行くと違う波なんですね
こちらですごい波が強いんだけど
向こうに行くとほとんど柔らかくなっているし
ですから 算時はこの連続性は
あるいは相속性あるんだけど
またそこに変わっていっちゃうんです
それを理解してほしい
我々がわかるのはこの細胞の分裂ぐらいなんですね
でもこの普通の物質もずっと
例えばテープレコーダーっていうのは五年間でも一応使えるかもしれません
ということは  五 年間は結構この相속性を持ってるんです
もし五年間のテープレコーダーが全く同じ現象の連続だったら
五年経っても新品同様のものなんですね
でもそうじゃないんです
買ったものとはほぼ同じなんですけど
全く同じものではないんです
それは物を使っても使わなくても
例えばよくやることで
高い服いっぱい買ってタンスに詰まっておくでしょ
一度も使ってないんだけど
後で十年経ったところで
あの着物は昔買ったんだけど
じゃあ今度の結婚式に着ますってところでもう古くなってるんです
一度も使わなくたっても
それはしょうがないんです
でも違う着物になったんだということでもないんです
私は買ったのは赤い着物で鶴の絵が絵があったんでよと
今あるのはもう青い で
もう菊の花の模様ですよという風にはないんです
それはもう十年経ったところでも赤くてする絵があるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりもう違うんですね
ですから その中でこの算時
生殖という場合は その変化も考えなくて
ただ相속することだけ
連続することだけここで考える
ウペッチャイの場合は集まることだけ考える
集まることだけ考えると
物が増えるわ増えるわ増えるわ
ありがたい話なんですね
お金でも金でも銀でも
どこかに置いておけばエネルギーは吸収するんだから
外から そこで金はどんどんどんどん大きくなっていくわ
どんどんどんどん大きくなっていくわってことなんですけど
その性質あるんです あるんだけど
また違うラッカナを持ってるんですね
そこで自分が自分の金庫の中に宝石やら金やら入れて
次の一年経ったところで開けてみたら
それはまあどうやらアルミになっているならば悲しいことですけど
やっぱりそうはならないんですね
金のアクセサリーだったら十年経ってから開けてみたっても
金は金なんですね その場合は集めてないんだけど
相속しているんです 同じ現象は
それだけ でも相속だけありがたいんだったら
一回ピカピカの金のアクセサリーが十年経っても同じくピカピカの金のアクセサリーであるはずなんですけど
そうではないんですね
それですから もうもう一つ特色あるんじゃないかと考えなくちゃいけない
もう一つの特色はウペッテーカンパテギャルカ
我々が勉強してた時は
あまりそういうところは説明全くしなかったんです
別に変化するということやと言って
それで終わったんです
一応面白いんだからね
先生も私はもう四十年前に勉強したことです
で 勉強してた時は説明してもらわなかったところは
今一生懸命説明してるんです
で 次の特色が出ている